faut que je réponde texto tu as dit je
lui écris quoi soit cool quoi on voit
lui un et mogi au beaucoup d'accords
soit cool
voici le monde secret caché à
l'intérieur de votre téléphone
là où les màj comme moi travaillent et
vivent ici chacun nous ne fait qu'une
seule chose mais à chaque fois on a
intérêt à assurer messages entrants on
demande bob a acquis moi qui fabrique
ses 32 buts
c'est quoi ces thèmes au gie mon pote
gilles et d'alléger problème est comment
tu fais ça je le fais c'est tout ce que
je sais tu peux nous aider
suivez-moi il faut sortir du téléphone
pour trouver le code source route à
puget net
on doit trouver le mot de passe bonjour
c'est quoi le nom de la copine d'alex
déjà elle s'appelle sida sarah aurait
bien dit l'hôpital mais ça sonne pas
terrible on dirait plutôt le nom d'un
chihuahua
je trouve plutôt bien comme tu es
[Musique]
hu
personne petit le téléphone c'est privé
gifle un sentiment différent
je suis peut-être pas fait pour être une
seule émotion
moi je te plies candy cross domicilié à
leur ait plus jamais de bonbons ben oui
j'ai fait une overdose
tope là ne fait pas ça ne fait pas ça ce
truc est déjà allé dans ton ventre
pistons ont fait quoi après un groupe
oppose ce qu'on doit se laver les mains
aucun trophée
[Musique]